so this is what life now looks like for
Premier League stars in the age of
covert 19 Tottenham Hotspur was one of
the club's back training today in small
groups keeping their distance no
tackling and temperature checks on
arrival but not every player has been
happy about the resumption with concerns
about safety while we are gonna be a
very safe environment
it only takes one person to get
effective in the group for that to be a
one to a seat ratio and again I don't
want to be bringing at home and I've
just had my son's about five months old
they have breathing difficulties so I
don't want to come home to put him in
more danger
the Watford captain has had support
notably from Chelsea manager Frank
Lampard people like Troy Deeney you have
to give them the freedom to speak out
because people will be speaking from the
heart
some things will be more comfortable
about it I think we have to upgrade that
communication some players know what
they're going through and then they can
make those decisions because you know
they're that they're my lads are now and
I'm sure all managers will speak in the
same way they're good lads they're our
intentions and their feelings for their
family and how they feel good they want
to get here and work Germany's
Bundesliga returned at the weekend
behind closed doors
five weeks after their players resumed
training these two Brentford fans were
among many in this country who tuned in
they've been missing the game so much
they've been cycling around every ground
in London as you say for everyone to go
back in better if everyone could go to
the grounds in so yeah but for the
country self massive boost even even
Germany coming back is given the boost
here as well I was looking at the
Dortmund game I saw them I saw them go
one new heart but it looked like a ghost
town to see nobody there the fact the
fans make the game I think at the end of
the day you can be the best team in the
world but he's not got
fans there to support and backyard it's
not football when those specific date
has been set in stone for the Premier
League to return everyone is hoping it
will be at some point in June here at
Stamford Bridge well the matched a
countdown clock tells its own story
despite six positive tests our three
clubs the next step will be full contact
training and if that passes off safely
the Premier League albeit behind closed
doors we get the go-ahead to get playing
and the Brady Sky News at Stamford
Bridge